we are starting today with what are
effectively in a sense counter sanctions
sanctions issued not only sanctions but
also bans from the country of russia
issued by the kremlin against the number
of american officials up to and
including joe biden now there's not very
much
that's funny
about what's going on with the russian
invasion of ukraine there's there's just
very little that's funny in all of this
but
the sanctions and banning biden from
russia it's a little bit funny i will
tell you there's a newsweek piece about
this russia sanctions joe
and hunter biden which i just find
hilarious hillary clinton
and 10 others president joe biden his
son hunter biden hillary clinton and 10
other officials have been sanctioned by
russia in response to the sweeping
sanctions imposed by washington the
russian government announced today
yesterday rather the sanctions barred
the officials from entering russia
russia's foreign ministry said in a
statement translated to english that the
measures were on the basis of
reciprocity now here
it's actually beneficial that the people
that are sanctioned don't need to go to
russia
and don't have bank accounts in russia
and don't have assets in russia and it
makes it all pretty weak now you'll
remember that russian oligarchs
organizations and entities have been
targeted by u.s europe and canada in
response to the ukrainian uh invasion by
russia russian president putin himself
has been directly sanctioned
the translated russian foreign ministry
statement tuesday said the reciprocal
sanctions were the inevitable
consequence of the extremely russophobic
russophobic
course taken by the administration
others sanctioned by russia
secretary of state anthony blinken
defense secretary lloyd austin chairman
of the joint chiefs mark milley
cia director william joseph burns white
house press secretary jen saki even gen
saki
and a bunch of other people now jensaki
was asked about this yesterday and she
basically made the obvious points about
it um take a listen to this
sanctions sure we're imposed today by
russia against yourself
president biden and other top u.s
officials
do you have a response to that and how
will it impact any of you if at all sure
i would first note that president biden
is a junior so they may have sanctioned
his dad may he rest in peace can you
imagine i mean this is one of those
things where you know
in the united states
i love what gen saki is saying because
it's almost too on the nose and also
irrelevant if you understand how russia
works let me explain what i mean by that
on the one hand
in the u.s
if you sanction you know joseph biden
rather than joseph biden jr
you've not sanctioned the correct person
it doesn't matter what what your intent
was in some places there's other places
where intent does matter but it's sort
of like a legal question but we have the
general belief in the us we're like
that's a legit technicality where like
if you don't say that it's junior
it probably applies to someone other
than the person it's supposed to apply
to and jen saki's right about that
but the other thing you have to
understand is in russia it they don't
care about technicalities like that
if the intention was to sanction joe
biden the president of the united states
the fact that joe biden is biden's dad
deceased father they don't those are not
the types of technicalities that courts
in russia care about
unless it's to their advantage in which
case all sorts of technicalities you
couldn't even imagine will matter
there's a bunch of interesting books
that that talk about this including bill
browder's book i believe it's called red
notice he's been a guest on the show
even if you don't like bill browder or
you don't find him trustworthy his
explanation of how
the the justice system is a very
amorphous thing in russia are are quite
quite interesting uh let's get a little
more here from gensake
the second piece i would say is that
won't surprise any of you uh that none
of us are planning uh tourist trips to
russia none of us have bank accounts
that we won't be able to access so we
will forge ahead yeah at this point i
don't think anybody is really looking to
go to russia from american leadership
it's interesting that hillary's on the
list
but no trump sanction no trump ban
also notable and interesting
and of course
this is serious fuel for the conspiracy
theorists the conspiracy theorists are
hearing this
and uh they are
coming up with all sorts of different
hypotheses about why this is the list
and why is hillary on the list that
that's that's a really really big deal
uh to them
um anything else of interest here
um
oh this is notable at the same time
russia does not refuse to maintain
official relations if they meet our
national interests so they're making it
clear that even though these people are
are banned and not allowed in russia
if there were
some particular reason why they would
want to meet with people or maintain a
diplomatic relation they will do that of
course that that makes perfect sense not
a big surprise
imagine
if they included
hunter biden's laptop on the list that
would be pretty fascinating that would
be pretty fascinating one of our
sponsors is cometier coffee cometeer
coffee is delicious i can tell you
firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds
then the coffee is flash frozen locking
in the flavor it arrives at your home
frozen in a fully recyclable capsule all
you have to do is melt it by adding hot
water or cold water for iced coffee it
takes seconds it's the most convenient
way that i have ever made coffee i've
been impressed with how the process
protects the flavor i really enjoy
cometier they have a variety of flavor
options light medium and dark single
origin and blended coffee roasts from
the best specialty roasters you'll get
twenty dollars off when you go to
cometeer.com pacman the link is
underneath this video